good morning Hank it's Wednesday as you
know sometimes a nerdfighter meets
another nerdfighter and they fall a
nerdfighter like well today I present
you with four stories of nerd love in
all its many splendors let's begin with
phil and TJ hank you may remember that a
couple years ago i was part of a
nerdfighter marriage proposal
nerdfighter flashback it's still there
with you by the way
will you marry him
so hiccup date not only are filling TJ
happily married they are expecting their
first child whoa whoa it looks like I
got so excited about Phil and TJ's baby
that I had an accident and now I'm
seated in a pool of cheap champagne
what's new anyway TJ has one of the
funniest blogs on the entire internet
chronicling this pregnancy with helpful
diagrams of her fetus eating its feet
and stuff check it out a link in the
doobly-doo although I should note that
that blog does contain Frank language I
mean to be fair it's possible to be
pregnant without cursing but it's
definitely not advisable Story number
two Connor and Amy God there is a lot of
champagne in my pants right now okay a
boy and his air force bear go into the
woods hold on yeah I thought that
tenants might be unprecedented so a boy
and his air force bear go into the woods
and they ask Amy to homecoming then the
boy submits the picture to fvi
nerdfighters they run it and a few days
later she responds dear Connor
homecoming sounds beautiful I'll paint
my nails electric blue in honor of
Alaska god it's so cute like don't we
bear it get it bear it because of the
bear I'm drunk aren't I I'm drunk
because there's champagne in my chair
that's traveled into my pants that's
then gone through my skin and into my
body I'm not a scientist but I believe
that's called osmosis anyway Hank they
did go to homecoming but you know that
was six months ago which a nerdfighter
liked is a long time and we all know
that every relationship ends you know
either breakup divorce or death so the
update is they're still together yes
story three my face plus your torso
equals nerdfighter like so Hank I
recently got an email from Janis
pictured here in which she told me that
she was wearing her Pizza John shirt in
her elementary statistics class because
you know what else you gonna wear to
elementary statistics and this boy
Andrew walked up to her and said are you
a nerdfighter and she said no I just
love pizza and men with creeper
mustaches no she said yes yes i'm a
nerdfighter and then he was like i'm on
my way to a gas meeting the gaming and
anime society perhaps you'd like to join
me and of course he said yes and now
they're a nerdfighter like huzzah gasps
the gaming and anime society couldn't
you have called it the Society for anime
and gaming sag story for the boy from
the bookstore okaying so a few weeks ago
a nerdfighter is in a Barnes & Noble in
Bel Air Maryland she gets to talking to
a cute boy and it turns out that they
are both nerdfighters but then they go
their separate ways without exchanging
any kind of contact information and then
this girl writes us and says can you
please help me track down my nerdfighter
crush so listen up if you are five foot
seven you have brown air and blue eyes
and you were recently in the Bel Air
Maryland Barnes & Noble talking to a
girl about nerd fighting let us know
Hank those are my stories of nerd love I
hope they make you as happy as they made
me three other things first this shiny
little number will Grayson Will Grayson
just came out in paperback yesterday if
you want to buy it there's a link to do
so in the doobly-doo secondly
nerdfighters Jimmy nerdfighter like
stories if so leave them in comments and
finally Hank your videos about Haiti
continue to be an inspiration to me and
to all of nerdfighteria - thank you I
have made a three hundred dollar gift to
water.org nerdfighters if you would like
to join me in giving and following our
community in Haiti check out the link in
the dooblydoo it occurs to me there are
a lot of links in the doobly-doo today
but they're all good ones Hank I'm gonna
go change pants I'll see you on Friday